[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to reboot
GameSpot's opinion editorial show I'm
Mike McCarty and I'm Jake Decker and if
you watched last week's episode then you
know this is kind of halfway between
season 1 and two of reboot we're gonna
kind of try to do eight or so episodes a
season we used III a couple weeks ago in
Los Angeles to divide the season so last
episode in our ending we asked people
for suggestions with the show going
forward we want to talk about those
today we want to talk about what we saw
at e3 and we also just wanted to talk
about what we're excited to cover in the
coming season or so whatever you wanna
call it of reboot so we do have like one
comment that actually this comment was
kind of prevalent throughout the YouTube
comments under the Red Dead Redemption -
and why you should love videogame delays
episode of reboot I we kind of wanted to
talk about this quickly before we do
move on to the future of reap so Jake if
you want to read it yeah this one's by
Joseph on youtube and he says I don't
mind game delays but I think publishers
and developers should really have a much
firmer idea when to release a game what
are your thoughts on that yeah I agree
um I I realized there are a lot of
things like we talked about in the last
episode that you know these catastrophes
can happen in these these studios can
undergo you know some behind the scenes
errors or you know just tumult and every
once in a while a game has to get pushed
back and you know like when developers
and publishers make that call to be
pretty refreshing to see that but this
reminds me of what Bethesda did this
year at e3 their press conference which
some people thought was not that great I
I actually thought the same thing at
first because oh we didn't see anything
major that's coming out in 2018 or 2019
but I actually liked that they said
here's Wolfenstein - here's the evil
within - here you know this is when
these games are going to be released and
they showed off the games like oh
they're clearly or at least you know
Wolfenstein 2 is clearly done people
played a lot of it afterwards but these
are the games that you can play before
the end of 2017 over the next six months
that was really refreshing because it
would have been cool to see an Elder
Scrolls 6 announcement or an obsidian
developed a fallout spin-off but you
know that would have been in the far
future and then by the time we actually
get to that release date maybe they'll
push it back again
maybe if Beyond Good and Evil 2 or The
Last Guardian or Final Fantasy 15 had
held off on their release dates
initially a little more than people
wouldn't kind of have such a negative
opinion of you know those games that
came out
you know final fantasy 15 the last
guardians who were both great but you
know now looking back you wonder if they
would have been better off in
development side of things if they had
held off on telling a release date yeah
and I think uh you brought up Elder
Scrolls 6 like people want to see a
teaser for that and I mean we all know
Elder Scrolls 6 is coming like they
don't need to save it
Oh Elder Scrolls 6 look I think they
have they've said it it's coming but
it'll be a while um so yeah I would much
rather have that announcement that I
would much rather Bethesda hold off on
that and just announce it when it's
ready kind of like what they did with
fallout so we know that okay we're going
to be getting this game on this date
however not I don't think all developers
can do that I think some developers
especially e3 they need that hype they
need people to get behind their games
early in order to spread the message to
share thoughts etc and there are also
huge teams behind games so it can be
tough to nail down an exact date but
yeah I think it would be better for
developers to say this game is coming in
2018 and then as we get closer announce
the date rather than give a date two
years in advance or whatever and yeah we
do have one more comment that we want to
bring up on YouTube from Brown Sean H I
fan tastic episode guys really like the
show overall structure was conducive to
conveying your opinions and you asked
hard questions which what the industry
needs I have a question how do you plan
to expand the show or adjust the format
for season 2 as in what new ideas are
you excited about so in general I think
for the time being we might not tease
the next episode we found that a lot of
times people in the comments were
excited to see this and then you know we
do the reboot up side they're like oh
great like what are you gonna do next
time and kind of built up these
expectations and it became a wall after
awhile because for the injustice 2
episode specifically I remember that's
the first one we really pivoted last
minute and I don't want to keep I don't
want to make we're talking about like
game delays and broken promises I don't
want to make a promise and then be like
[ __ ] I actually have something more
interesting to say about this game
despite the fact we promised this game
so for the time being I think we're
gonna stop teasing the episodes but we
will absolutely continue to look through
the comments to see what you want us to
cover in the future because we do have a
lot of episode ideas that we took out of
your input yeah I think a lot of these
topics too that we jump on well not a
lot of them but there's a good amount of
them that like a story will break the
day before and we'll be like holy [ __ ]
we should do something on this and then
you'll write the episode the next day
and then we'll edit reboot the following
day so it makes a lot more sense to hold
on to what we're gonna do but still like
keep giving us suggestions of what you'd
like us to cover because we do like to
touch on that as well yeah and then Jake
and I were talking I think on the last
episode that two cameras the stuff with
me on camera worked for what we were
talking about in the themes of the
episode I think we're gonna feel less
constricted in terms of what we should
have an on-camera thing here like I'm
gonna be playing this game I think after
a while the actual time it takes to film
and you know Jake when he's doing the
lighting and the actual shooting and
figuring out where to shoot this stuff
it takes some valuable time away from
research or editing which you know some
episodes like I said like the Red Dead
Redemption one made sense to have
on-camera stuff but in the future we're
not always going to have that so you
also bonus you don't see my dumb face
all the time in an apron yeah in an
apron uh but yeah but yeah I think that
more the future I I really do like
shooting these but I think Mike's right
and that not every episode needs it and
it feels forced a lot of times yeah we
still will shoot things like if it makes
sense um but I still like the Resident
Evil on our very first episode yeah for
example that like if we have an idea
like that we're definitely gonna be
shooting something like that however the
Mass Effect one maybe probably didn't
need to camera stuff but yeah so yeah
speaking of the war one people in the
comments throughout all videos and then
even this last video said I thought this
kind of this episode was shallow but
this one was really good and the one
that people frequently pointed to even
though it didn't do as well as some of
our other ones was the episode about
wargames
which makes me happy because that's my
favorite episode yeah same here I think
that's the one that had the most
research and that was originally gonna
be our first episode I think we said
before but I we're gonna keep trying to
take you know like actually not just
give our opinion about something other
people have given their opinion about
like game delays I still like that last
episode but I do in my opinion was one
of the weaker ones in terms of what I
wrote because so many other people have
had an opinion on delays it just seemed
dumb not to talk about it because I want
to
the way around the red dead red dead
redemption to delay and the shadow of
war delay which I will absolutely talk
more about that game in the future both
of those but but people like the war
episode and we want to keep that mind
moving forward like how can we look at
these this genre differently and kind of
offer our own take or you know the next
episode again I'm not gonna promise
anything about the one I'm kind of
writing right now is looking back at a
game that I absolutely adore that people
might not have played and I think you
should and I I'm like almost breaking my
promise not to tease episodes but yeah
we want to keep taking a new game or
like a game on its anniversary and
trying to look at it in a different
angle then other people have rather than
give our own opinion on the topic a lot
of other people have discussed already
which can be tough to do yeah it's not
always easy like finding a way to talk
about injustice to was like damn there's
so many things I love this game what do
we talk about you know it's the stuff
that jumps out at us and then a lot of
times Jake will hit me up with like a
suggestion I'll be like damn that's
actually cool we should run with that
yeah it's pretty much just you know
figuring out as we go Jake you and I
were just talking a few minutes ago
about Wolfenstein - the new Colossus I'm
a huge shooter fan and we both love the
first game from machine games and
Bethesda I'm sure will there'll be
something to talk about with that so
[ __ ] excited this game it looked off
did you play it no I didn't get it I
played I played a new order but I didn't
get a chance to play new Colossus but
yeah that first game I it was far from
perfect
liked it definitely had its missteps
it's had it it had its problems and I
wasn't too wild about the gameplay all
the time however I think that story is
one of the best like world war ii
stories ever told and it is completely
ridiculous alter history yeah I think PJ
Blass kovitch is one of the best first
person shooter characters which is
strange because he had no right to be
that good of a kid in the first game a
little interesting trivia the voice
actor Brian bloom is the the guy who
mocap tin to the voice acting and wrote
called to the infinite warfare if you
played that earlier protagonist yeah so
that's his incall dream for a warfare
like they use his face and his body and
his voice but that's also BJ I've no
idea
yes rad I'm looking forward to a night
it the more I think about it I'm
it's that and the far cry 5 is also an
interesting one we might touch on but
again that's a game that I feel like in
everyone's come to the themes yeah I
think everyone's going to want to talk
about so if we can't find an alternate
way to talk about that game like I'm
most interested in the structure and
mechanics of shooters if they have cool
themes that's awesome and an added bonus
obviously the war game episode we talked
how they can be deeper than just the
mechanics and the systems that are
overlapping but far cry 5 and
Wolfenstein 2 are both this like
occupied America kind of setting
Wolfenstein 2 on a much larger scale and
an alternate history but I'm really
looking forward to that so I'm sure
we'll talk about that and maybe far cry
5 no promise never bet you Wolfenstein
will be far better written for five if
they have the San team the outer i-5 was
fun though like don't get me wrong far
cry 5 was fun and to be fair we I'd I
played about an hour during e3 and we
didn't get to see really any of the
story we just played the game and
mechanically it was pretty good I'm just
curious to see how they handle the story
with that game maybe I'll use Far Cry
fives released as an opportunity to go
back and talk about Far Cry 2 one of the
best games ever made it has an ally
system in five that looks like you're
drawing from - yeah include hawk it
definitely is but it almost doesn't seem
as in-depth it sucks because that's
really cool yeah um speaking of inflate
that game speaking of like I was just
going to say that's like the Alma's
opposite you know like you devote if you
haven't played far cry 2 you develop
these allies that kind of have these
relationships to you almost like the
opposite of shadow of mordor's nemesis
system and speaking of that shadow war
I'm a huge Tolkien nerd I don't know if
it's just seeped into reboot yet and I'm
looking forward to this but I'm really
I'm actually I'm not worried but I'm
kind of apprehensive about shadow war
because as someone who played a ton of
shadow mordar shadow war looks like it's
going to be overwhelming as hell but how
many systems are overlapping
it still looks awesome and I'm glad they
delayed it because going back to last
episode I'm it looked seemed like they
had more time to kind of you know
congeal everything but I'm really
looking for that game that's not
mid-october if I'm not mistaken so
October's gonna be a hell of a month
yeah so yeah we have to keep in mind
that all these things were talking about
like I really would love to do a deep
deep dive into like a Mario games level
design like Super Mario to see how yeah
the same day as Wolfenstein - I would
love to actually look at how I got to
play Odyssey that's actually I was up on
the stage at e3 hosting
so the only game I actually got to play
on the show floor was Super Mario
Odyssey and it was still that's the one
game I'm happy I got to play because
it's awesome I'm really interested in
how they're taking the traditional 3d
Mario design level design and making it
into these sand boxes where you can go
every which way instead of this linear
path oh sorry oh has perfected I also
just love how batshit that game yes like
that I have no idea what what's going on
and again but I love it in the closer
future I'm really really really excited
about Mario Plus rabbits Kingdom battle
which I never thought I would say out
loud or before I saw it at the e3 press
conference that intend oh no sorry
Ubisoft it they announced on the stage
when Miyamoto came out of smoke holding
a [ __ ] dough the coolest thing that
happen to be three I can't wait to see
how they take that turn-based kind of
you know Fire Emblem XCOM maybe even
Final Fantasy Tactics formula and
implement it to this weird mashup of
Ubisoft and Nintendo icons I can't wait
for the game it's also gonna be on the
switch I'm really excited to try that
out maybe we'll talk about it we'll see
I don't know who knows yeah I think
another game that would be interesting
to talk about to maybe once again it's a
busy month but Assassin's Creed origins
I think what they're doing with that
game and series is really fascinating
they've taken a lot of cues from other
games in there they took they took some
time off and I think this game has the
potential to be interesting again yeah
I'm looking forward to that game
hopefully bringing me back to the
franchise which I haven't cared that
much about since Black Flag and honestly
even then I didn't like it for its
Assassin's Creed elements I liked it
because it's a pirate game which is now
full game and Skull and Bones kind of
Ubisoft I think in a smart move took the
pirate elements of that game and made it
into a full game which will release
sometime 2018 I don't think they have a
set date yet but and then one more that
I was stupid excited about when I saw on
the Microsoft stage was Metro exodus
from for AI games yeah yeah you from the
buek the Ukraine this metro 2033 and
last light some of the most like
underrated shooters ever especially last
light maybe not underrated but
underappreciated because not that many
people played it yeah I think it's still
a cult classic if you haven't played it
once you watch this start playing Metro
last light or 2033 and then go into last
light they're so well paced that you
could blow despite the fact that they're
both pretty lengthy shooter campaigns
you could probably blow through them in
a weekend just because like they're so
well paced unless you're playing on the
hardest difficulty Ranger mode which I
recommend it's it's it's tough um yeah I
think when we heard the rumor that
Microsoft might be sharing a new Metro
game for the Xbox one X I think both of
us were by far the most excited people
in the office cuz I loved last slide ya
know I mean like we should probably cut
it off there cuz we've been talking a
while and we basically you know a lot of
people were saying it wasn't the best e3
but I thought it was actually pretty
exciting based on a lot of stuff and you
know we could keep going on all day
about the games we want to cover but
yeah again if you've been watching every
episode of reboot up till now
or even just joined us and want to go
back and watch our previous ones we
absolutely love having all your input in
the comments and reading the comments
after we publish these videos or like
getting tweets about the show whether
it's criticism or you know like agreeing
with us or praise or anything honestly
it's awesome you the best part of the
show that's why we do these episodes
these off week episodes where we talk
directly to you keep it coming keep all
the input the constructive criticism
coming keep the arguments coming we love
to see people present other sides of you
that's like half the point of the show
we're gonna keep doing it and I just is
that I guess a tip but I think the
easiest way to get a hold of us is
through Twitter if you have a question
because while we don't mind like well we
always pour through all the YouTube
comments
uh it's it's easier when it's on Twitter
because that questions right in front of
us rather than us trying to dig through
it yeah so there's a little tip I guess
if you want your question featured on
the show one of these days yeah but now
the ìiî is done we're back on schedule
so we will have an episode a week from
today if you're watching this on Sunday
and looking forward to that already
start writing it but again not going to
tease it in case we pivot last second
but I am really really excited about
this one so yeah hopefully we'll see you
in seven days and until then maybe go
back and catch up on past episodes or
play all these the predecessors to all
these sequels we just mentioned yes
Metro Wolfenstein all the Mario games
yeah it's a that's your homework in the
next seven days beat every Mario game
alright we'll see you next week
yeah
[Music]